heute widmen wir uns einer für die ganze
Weltwirtschaft wichtigen Frage steht die
chinesische Wirtschaft kurz vor einer
großen Wirtschafts- und Finanzkrise
könnte das bislang so erfolgreiche
sogenannte chinesische Modell
zusammenbrechen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
liebe visualpolitik Community noch im
Jahr 2020 versprach die chinesische
Regierung ihren Bürgern weitgehendes und
allgemeines Wohlergehen sozusagen friede
freude Frühlingsrolle das Land hatte
sich dem von Donald Trump entfesselten
Handelskrieg gestellt und war eines der
ersten Länder dass die kovik 19 Pandemie
bei sich massiv einnimmt denn obwohl die
Pandemie in China ihren Ursprung nahm
hat die chinesische Wirtschaft damals
als eine der besten weltweit
abgeschnitten seitdem haben sich die
Dinge jedoch grundlegend geändert schaut
es euch an 22 juli 2022 Chinas Wachstum
bricht stark ein BIP Ziel wird
unerreichbar im zweiten Quartal 2022
wuchte chinesische Wirtschaft nur noch
um 0,4 Prozent mit Ausnahme der
Coronavirus era war dies der
schlechteste Wert der letzten 30 Jahre
ungefährdet das Wachstumsziel von 5,5%,
dass ich die Regierung von Shisha bin
für das gesamte Jahr gesetzt hatte
[Musik]
also vergesst jetzt am besten alles was
ihr über Chinas Erfolg wisst denn jetzt
in diesem Jahr befindet sich das Reich
der Mitte in einem Szenario das
entgegengesetzter nicht sein könnte seit
der zweiten Hälfte 2021 braucht sich bei
dem asiatischen Giganten eine Art
wirtschaftliche Orkan zusammen die
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit steht kurz davor
über die 20% Marke zu klettern
Einzelhandel lang so sehr dass seine
realen Umsätze rückläufig sind die
Immobilienpreise sind seit dem Sommer
2021 gefallen und zu allem Überfluss ist
wie ihr dieser Grafik nehmen könnt die
Kapitalflucht aus dem Land in die Höhe
gestellt und hat einen Großteil des
enormen handelsüberschusses des Landes
aufgefressen china ist in
Schwierigkeiten unabhängig von den
Schlagzeilen wegen Taiwan sind die
kapitalabflüsse jetzt so groß wie 2015
und 16 als man die Abwertung des Yuan
fürchtete das liegt am starken Dollar
und daran das ausländische Investoren
China nach Russlands Einmarsch in der
Ukraine in einem neuen Licht sehen sogar
in einem Sektor mal das kronju will der
chinesischen Wirtschaft wahr ist das
Wachstum unbeständig geworden sieht mal
her
tatsächlich entlassen Giganten wie
Alibaba Tencent und die die und viele
andere Firmen die eines der Motor des
China Boos waren eine große Zahl von
Mitarbeitern das liegt einerseits an der
schlechten Wirtschaftslage und
andererseits daran dass der Druck den
Peking auf diese Unternehmen ausübt
deren Rentabilität beeinträchtigt hat
Chinas große textfirmen entlassen
tausende von Beschäftigten tatsache ist
das dieses Szenario die Regierung dazu
gezwungen hat große öffentliche
Unternehmen und den Staatsapparat selbst
aufzufordern mehr junge Leute
einzustellen damit die Lage nicht
vollkommen außer Kontrolle gerät aber
wie ihr bereits ahnst dürfte bei solchen
Maßnahmen das Motto gelten wie gewonnen
so zerronnen die wohl einzige gute
Nachricht für die chinesische Wirtschaft
im ersten Halbjahr 22 war dass die
ausländischen Direktinvestition trotz
allem stark gestiegen sind aber wie ihr
sehen könnt gibt es viel mehr negative
als positive Daten die Frage ist also
wie schlecht steht es wirklich um Chinas
Wirtschaft und warum sieht der Sturm
dass ich dort zusammen so
besorgniserregend aus für das
postkommunistische Riesenreich wie für
die ganze Welt wie nah sind wir an einem
möglichen Crash mit anschließendem
Dominoeffekt was gedenktischen Ping zu
tun um zu verhindern dass China eine
derart monumentale Krise erlebt wie seit
mehr als 50 Jahren nicht mehr all diese
Fragen werden wir sofort nach einem
kurzen Werbehinweis unseres treuen
Sponsors surfschlag beantworten denn
surfshark VPN ist ein wirklich
empfehlenswertes und sicheres VPN
welches zum Beispiel keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mit lockt natürlich
kann ein worcial private Network kurzvpn
einen nicht vor allen gefahrenschützen
die im Netz lauern man muss nach wie vor
Umsicht walten lassen und wissen was man
tut aber es stellt hierfür ein Werkzeug
mit gleich mehreren Vorteilen da zum
einen erschwert ist in Kombination mit
anderen Vorkehrungen eure Aktionen im
Netz nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören mit
Hilfe verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures
könnt ihr so eure Anonymität im Netz
erhöhen z.B mit dem integrierten clean
Web das alle Cookies Pop-Ups und so
weiter blockt weiterer Vorteil eines VPN
ist dass ihr so tun könnt als während
ihr an einem anderen Ort so könnt ihr
Beispiel auf Websites und
Internetdienste zugreifen die in dem
Land in dem wir gerade Seiten nicht
verfügbar wären ob daheim oder im Urlaub
damit schlagt die Zensur und geoblocking
ein Schnäppchen Netflix und anderes
Training Dienste die ihre Inhalte nur in
den USA Anbieten von Europa ausnutzen
oder deutsches Internet fernsehen im
Ausland gucken mit surfshark kein
Problem aber das ist noch lange nicht
alles denn mit nur einem surfshark Konto
könnt ihr wirklich alle eure Endgeräte
im VPN registrieren Handys Notebooks und
sogar euren Smart TV so und wenn ihr den
Rabattcode politik.de angibt bekommt ihr
von surfshark auch noch eine Rabatt von
83% und obendrein die ersten drei Monate
gratis dazu den Link zu diesem Angebot
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video also nichts wie los besorgt
euch gerade damit auch gleichzeitig uns
finanziell unter die Arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe des
PayPal Spenden links den ich euch
ebenfalls in die Beschreibung gepackt
habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung dankbar denn damit hält
ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr und
noch bessere Videos zu liefern und nun
ab nach Ostasien wo sich momentan ein
gigantischer Sturm zusammenbraut also
ich euch gut fest
[Musik]
wie weit gehen die Probleme
im Gegensatz zum Rest der Welt beschloss
sich chinesische Zentralbank Mitte
August 2022 eine Zinssenkung mit 15
August 2022 China schockiert mit
zinsenkungen angesichts eines
alarmierenden wirtschaftseinbruchs und
nicht nur das gleichzeitig kündigte die
Regierung eine Erhöhung der öffentlichen
Ausgaben an aber Moment mal niedrigere
Zinsen und zugleich mehr Stars Ausgaben
das bedeutet dass ich die chinesische
Regierung so verhält als befindet sich
das Land bereits in einer Krise oder
sogar in einer Rezession und genau das
ist auch das was uns die Daten sagen die
wir aktuell zu sehen bekommen es ist
nicht einfach genau zu wissen was in
China vor sich geht wir reden hier
schließlich nicht gerade über das
transparenteste Land der Welt die
Situation scheint jedoch schlimmer zu
sein als es das von der Regierung
geschätzte BIP-Wachstum widerspiegelt
China ist schließlich ein Land das weder
nach dem Massaker auf dem Platz des
Himmlischen Friedens noch in der
asiatischen Finanzkrise 1997 oder im
Krisenjahr 2007 offiziell relativ
Wachstum verbucht hat und es wäre nicht
das erste Mal dass die Regierenden in
China bei der Fälschung ihrer
Wirtschaftsdaten überführt werden wir
haben sogar mal ein eigenes Video
darüber gedreht wie dort die
Manipulation von Statistiken schon seit
Jahrzehnten systemisch angelegt ist ich
werde es Euch natürlich verlinken damit
ihr es euch im Anschluss gleich ansehen
könnt eine hochgradig interessante
Thematik in Anbetracht dessen sagt die
Tatsache dass China sein schlechtestes
Wachstum der letzten 30 Jahre sogar
publik gemacht hat viel darüber aus wie
die Dinge wohl wirklich laufen nicht
gerade rosig aber wie weit reichen die
Probleme Chinas wirklich was sind heute
die größten Löcher in der chinesischen
Wirtschaft okay lasst uns mal die fünf
größten Probleme unter die Lupe nehmen
welche die wirtschaftliche Zukunft
dieses Landes belasten und die mögliche
Reaktion der Regierung wie sie die
schlechten Daten die wir gesehen haben
wieder in den Griff bekommen möchte
der erste Punkt hat viel mit der
grundlegenden Funktionsweise
chinesischen Wirtschaft zu tun während
das BIP in den meisten Teilen der Welt
ein Maß dafür ist wie viele im Land über
einen bestimmten Zeitraum hinweg
produziert wurde ist dass in China etwas
anders das BIP würde dort im Prinzip
dasselbe messen wenn es denn überhaupt
messen würde denn der Unterschied ist
dass es in China ein politisch
bestimmter Indikator ist der im Voraus
festgelegt wird das heißt die Regierung
liegt ein Wachstumsziel fest und drängt
dann alle staatlichen und auch privaten
Akteure dieses Ziel irgendwie zu
erreichen in gewisser Weise also ein
Stück guter alter Planwirtschaft
und ihr fragt euch wo das Problem liegt
tja wenn es den Beamten und
funktionieren scheint das dieses
Wachstum nicht erreicht werden kann
greifen Sie zu allen möglichen Tricks
und Maßnahmen um es halt doch noch zu
erreichen
sie stoßen sich zum Beispiel wie
verrückt in den Bau von Infrastruktur
und in alle möglichen Großprojekte sie
bringen Staatsunternehmen dazu Personal
einzustellen als gäbe es kein Morgen und
sie weiten die Kreditvergabe ungebremst
aus damit zum Beispiel Familien immer
mehr Häuser kaufen und so das Wachstum
ankurbeln sie würden wirklich alles tun
um das Jahresziel zu erreichen hinzu
kommt dass der größte Teil des
Bankensektors in China staatlich ist das
heißt er arbeitet für die Ziele der
Regierung und der Partei und wenn diese
mehr Wachstum vorgeben vergeben die
Banken eben wie verrückt neue Kredite
denn selbst wenn solche Kredite an
Privatpersonen oder Unternehmen mit nur
zweifelhafter Zahlungsfähigkeit gehen es
ist egal es spielt keine Rolle denn es
gilt die vom Staat festgelegten Ziele
für die kred Vergabe zu erfüllen damit
diese wiederum dazu beitragen die
Wachstumsziele zu erreichen merkt ihr wo
der Hase begraben liegt
[Musik]
durch ein kopfloses investieren nur um
das Investierens Willen entsteht eine
gigantische fehlalokation von Ressourcen
Geisterstädte in denen man wohnen will
Unternehmen deren Dienste niemand
benötigt und jede Menge
bullshit-arbeitsplätze statt sinnvoller
wirtschaftliche Aktivität gibt es nur
jede Menge wirtschaftsaktionismus der
zwar nach emsiger Betriebsamkeit
aussieht und viele Ressourcen verbraucht
aber keine nachhaltigen Werte schafft
das ganze geht so lange gut wie die
Illusion aufrechterhalten bleiben können
und die Ressourcen nicht ausgehen doch
dann plasst die Blase und je später
desto gewaltiger allerdings viele Jahre
lang war das alles kein wirkliches
Problem denn China war unter investiert
es hatte zu wenig Infrastruktur zu
wenige Unternehmen und es herrschte
Wohnraummangel das meiste was angepackt
wurde war also auch enorm produktiv
machte durchaus Sinn doch schon seit 10
bis 15 Jahren hat sich die Situation
geändert in China wurde so viel gebaut
dass ich jetzt zum Beispiel neue
Infrastruktur Objekte oder der Ausbau
der Kapazitäten
Unternehmen nicht mehr lohnen mit
anderen Worten sie erwirtschaften nicht
mehr genug Rendite um die getätigten
Investitionen auszugleichen das Ergebnis
eine riesige Schuldenspirale schaut euch
mal das hier an
[Musik]
die Verschuldung in China hat sich also
allein zwischen 2007 und 2017
vervierfacht ein Anstieg der größer ist
als der jedes anderen Landes wohlgemerkt
aus dieser Zahl ist sogar der
Finanzsektor ausgeklammert der bildet
ein Thema für sich das für uns gleich
ansehen werden fakt ist im Verhältnis zu
BIP haben die Chinesen heute sogar mehr
Schulden als die Bürger der Vereinigten
Staaten und das bringt uns nun direkt
zum zweiten Problem
während nämlich die Verschuldung stark
angestiegen ist ist die Produktivität
die letztlich ausschlaggebend ist für
die Fähigkeit diese Schulden abzuzahlen
stark gesunken das bedeutet das China
sehr viele Ressourcen investieren muss
um das Wachstum aufrecht zu erhalten und
das sind wie wir schon gesehen haben
Investitionen die mit Schulden
finanziert werden und dennoch wenig
Rendite abwerfen und was liebe
visualpolitik Zuschauer passiert wenn
eure Schulden in die Höhe schießen eure
Zahlungsfähigkeit jedoch schrumpft und
obendrein euer Geschäft in eine Krise
gerät und ihr Einkommenseinbußen habt
tja dann habt ihr ein Problem und vor
allem haben eure Banken ein noch viel
größeres Problem warum weil viele eurer
Kredite in Verzug geraten können das
heißt die Schuldner können nicht in der
Lage sein sie zu bezahlen das setzt dann
im schlimmsten Fall einen fatalen
Dominoeffekt im Gang und dies ist nun
schon das dritte große Risiko das dritte
große Problem der chinesischen
Wirtschaft die Möglichkeiten einer
großen Finanzkrise wir werden darüber
auch sehr bald detailliert in einem
eigenen Video berichten denn dieses
Thema ist wahrlich gewaltig in seinem
Ausmaß als auch seinen Auswirkungen für
die gesamte Welt wirtschaftlich und
geostrategisch also vergesst bitte nicht
visualpolitik zu abonnieren und ganz
wichtig die Glocke zu aktivieren falls
ihr nichts verpassen wollt kommen wir
nun zum vierten großen Problem das eng
mit dem dritten und mit allem was wir
bereits erwähnt haben zusammenhängt die
Implosion des Immobilienmarktes also das
Platzen einer riesen Blase in der
Bauwirtschaft
dieser Markt ist in China einfach
gigantisch um euch eine Vorstellung zu
geben allein im Jahr 2021 wurden in
China Wohnungen zum Preis von 2,4
Billionen Dollar verkauft also
2400 Milliarden Dollar direkt und
indirekt macht dieser Sektor fast 30 %
der gesamten chinesischen Wirtschaft aus
der Bausektor ist also kein
Nebenschauplatz sondern einer der
wichtigsten Wirtschaftsmotoren des
Riesenreichs nun seit den Sommer 2021
geht es in diesem Sektor jedoch immer
weiter Berg ab Investitionen
Immobilienverkäufe und Preise brechen
ein
erstes September 2022 69 chinesische
Städte melden sinkende Wohnungspreise
auch Peking Chinas Immobilienkrise
schlägt auf den Wert von Wohnungen durch
und das ist noch nicht alles capital
economics einen London ansässiges
Beratungsunternehmen stellte fest dass
es in China Ende 2021 etwa 30 Millionen
und verkaufte Immobilien und weitere
etwa 100 Millionen zwar verkaufte aber
unbewohnte Immobilien gab
[Musik]
und da der Immobiliensektor einen so
großen Teil des chinesischen Wirtschaft
ausmacht könnte ein Kollaps dieses
Sektors äußerst schwerwiegende Folgen
für die gesamte chinesische Wirtschaft
haben der Zusammenbruch dieser Branche
könnte zu 100.000 wenn nicht Millionen
von Arbeitslosen führen aber auch zur
Pleite vieler Bauträger vielen weiteren
Problemen im Banksektor und eine
allgemeine Verarmung der Chinesen
aufgrund des Wertverlusts ihrer
Immobilien denn was man wissen muss
Immobilien besitzt macht den größten
Teil der Vermögenswerte chinesischer
Familien aus und wenn die Hauspreise
fallen werden diese von riesigen
Hypotheken belasteten Familien plötzlich
viel ärmer und landen in vielen Fällen
auch in der Überschuldung die Situation
ist so heikel dass Videos wie dieses in
den chinesischen Netzwerken viral
gegangen sind
[Applaus]
[Musik]
tja nicht unbedingt denn irgendwann wird
auch der Platz knapp und so zu handeln
scheint auch nicht gerade ratsam zu sein
denn niemand kann in vier Immobilien
gleichzeitig leben
anstatt die Ursachen zu lösen bläht
diese Strategie die Blase nur zusätzlich
auf und damit die Folgen ihres Platzens
dieses wird zwar noch etwas
hinausgezögert verhindern kann man es
aber nicht Fazit anstatt die Probleme zu
lösen werden sie nur noch größer
[Musik]
tja und das fünfte Problem das auf China
zukommt hat viel mit dem Krieg in der
Ukraine zu tun der von Donald Trump
angezettelte Handelskrieg und die
gleichzeitig wachsende Aggressivität
Pickings haben bei vielen Unternehmen
die Alarmglocken schrillen lassen und
jetzt haben die russische Invasion in
der Ukraine und die Null covic-politik
der chinesischen Regierung das
geopolitische Risiko und die Bedeutung
der Absicherung von Lieferketten in der
ganzen Welt wieder in aller Deutlichkeit
hervorgehoben sie haben viele
multinationale Konzerne dazu veranlasst
eine Teil ihrer Betriebe zu verlagern
sich geografisch zu diversifizieren und
ihre neuen Investitionen in den nächsten
Jahren außerhalb Chinas zu konzentrieren
und ein großer Teil dieser Entwicklung
ist noch gar nicht geschehen aber die
Unternehmen sind sichtlich besorgt wenn
also die Investitionen ausländische
Unternehmen im Land letztlich
heruntergeschraubt werden dürfte dies
ein weiterer schwerer Schlag für das
chinesische Wirtschaftswachstum werden
mit anderen Worten dies könnte den
Aufschwung nicht nur ernsthaft behindern
sondern total abwürgen erschwerend kommt
hinzu dass die internationale
energiepreiskrise kurzfristig zu einem
Rückgang der globalen Kaufkraft und
damit der chinesischen Exporte führen
könnte was die wirtschaftlichen Probleme
des Giganten weiter verschärfen durfte
und schließlich müssen wir auch die
demografische Entwicklung
berücksichtigen auch wenn dies nicht
unmittelbar sondern erst Mittel- und
langfristige Folgen haben wird
[Musik]
China altert in hohem Tempo und so wie
es aussieht schrumpft die Bevölkerung in
erwerbsfähigen Alter bereits heute das
wird in den nächsten Jahren auch mit der
Bevölkerung des Landes insgesamt
geschehen denn gleichzeitig ist die
Geburtenrate in China im Jahr 2021 auf
eine historischen Tiefstand gefallen
dabei wurden bereits 2020 offiziell nur
12 Millionen chinesische Babys geboren
so wenige wie zuletzt 1960 die Pandemie
die in China kein Ende zu nehmen scheint
und die knallharten lockdown-maßnahmen
der Regierung hinterlassen in der
ohnehin traurigen Demografie Chinas eine
extrem tiefe Spur derzeit befinden sich
noch immer 33 Städte mit insgesamt 65
Millionen Einwohnern in lockdowns denn
skijimpings strengen 0 kobit Strategie
wird seit zweieinhalb Jahren eisern
aufrecht erhalten eine Kehrtwende würde
das eingestehen ihres Scheiterns und
damit einen enormen Gesichtsverlust für
den Diktator bedeuten eine ihrer Folgen
ist auch die vorhin erwähnte hohe
Arbeitslosigkeit vor allem unter jungen
Menschen zurzeit ist offiziellen Daten
jeder fünfte unter 25 Jahren arbeitslos
gleichzeitig explodieren die
Lebenshaltungskosten in den Städten und
die Kosten für Bildung dadurch wird den
Menschen die Grundlage für die
Familiengründung entzogen in den
vergangenen zwei Jahren sank die Zahl
der Eheschließungen und weitere 850.000
und das von einem ohnehin Grotten
schlechten Niveau für das kommende Jahr
wird deswegen auch mit einem erneuten
Geburtenrückgang gerechnet es liegt
daher auf der Hand dass eine
schrumpfende und immer ältere
Bevölkerung zu immer größeren
Belastungen weniger wirtschaftlicher
Dynamik und einer höheren pro
kopfverschuldung führen wird und es ist
auch vollkommen klar dass eine alternde
Bevölkerung die ehrgeizigen Pläne der
Regierung nicht umsetzen können
[Musik]
sogar die staatliche chinesische
Akademie der Wissenschaften
prognostizierte bereits 2019 das dem
staatlichen Rentenfonds bis 2035 das
Geld ausgeben werde wohlgemerkt das
waren die offiziellen Zahlen vor der
Pandemie die Realität heute durfte daher
noch wesentlich düsterer Aussehen der
die offiziellen Zahlen sind auch hier
krass verfälscht expertenschädungen
zufolge liegen z.B die realen
Geburtenzahlen um über 20% unter den
staatlichen Angaben der lokale Behörden
die Zahlen oft aufblasen um mehr
Subventionen von den Zentralregierung zu
bekommen doch deren Führung lebt umgeben
von ja sagern in ihrer selbst
geschaffenen informationsblase und hat
an der Erfassung realistischer
demografie-daten kein Interesse so
schlimm wäre das Erwachen aus der
eigenen Illusion tatsache ist dass die
vorgenannten fünf großen akuten Probleme
plus das sechste langfristige und noch
viel gewaltigere Problem die Demografie
einen ernsthaften Gegenwind für Chinas
wirtschaftlichen Höhenflug darstellen es
du damit klar sein dass der Aufstieg
Chinas in den letzten Jahren erleben
durften nur vorübergehender Natur war
und eine rasche langfristiger Niedergang
folgen wird an ein aufholen oder gar
überholen der USA ist da gar nicht mehr
zu denken denn China wird langfristig in
allen demografischen Parametern
schlechte Abschneiden als die USA denn
während deren Bevölkerung bis 2050 von
heute 330 auf rund 400 Millionen wachsen
durfte wird für die Chinas eine Rückgang
von 1,28 auf rund eine Milliarde
prognostiziert mit einer noch krasseren
Schrumpfung der Erwerbsbevölkerung und
der Produktivität aber es könnte für die
Chinesen noch viel schlimmer kommen als
nur die ewige Nummer 2 zu sein falls die
Regierung die erwähnten Probleme
weiterhin so angeht wie bisher könnte es
am Ende dazu wirklich großen Absturz
kommen der eine ernsthafte Wirtschafts-
und Finanzkrise in China verursachen und
auch einen globalen Crash auslösen
könnte
denn real steht momentan die Gefahr im
Raum dass das sogenannte chinesische
Modell zusammenbrechen könnte und eine
tatsächliche Reformbereitschaft ist weit
und breit nicht zu erkennen daraus
ergibt sich die aktuell wohl wichtigste
Frage gedenkt die Regierung Pinks
wirklich so weiter zu machen oder hat
sie doch noch etwas in petto umlegt ganz
große Gefahr abzuwenden ich denke
angesichts dessen was hier auf dem Spiel
steht lohnt es sich mal nachzusehen also
aufgepasst
[Musik]
oder Lucy das große Scheitern des Ping
okay ich weiß was viele von euch denken
Marc bleibt mal ganz locker alle Länder
erleben doch irgendwann einmal
wirtschaftswährungs- und Finanzkrisen
von den USA über die Europäische Union
bis hin zu Japan und Südkorea hast du
schweigen von Lateinamerika ist es
vielleicht nicht ein bisschen
übertrieben vom möglichen Crash des
ganzen chinesischen Modells zu sprechen
nur weil ein paar Wirtschaftsindikatoren
gerade nicht so gut aussehen nun
oberflächlich betrachtet schon aber wenn
wir unter die Motorhaube gucken absolut
nicht
[Musik]
jahrzehntelang bestand das chinesische
Modell darin der Bevölkerung eine
schnelle Verbesserung des
Lebensstandards zu garantieren wenn ich
Chinesen im Gegenzug dafür die Regierung
und die Macht der Kommunistischen Partei
nicht in Frage stellen das war so eine
Art stillschweigendes ungeschriebenes
Abkommen mit den die chinesischen
Machthaber ihre Herrschaftsform
legitimiert haben so war es auch während
der Amtszeiten von dangermin und Hugin
Tao um dies zu ermöglichen war die
Öffnung und Integration Chinas in die
Weltwirtschaft unabdingbar unter Shisha
in pink haben sich die Dinge jedoch
grundlegend geändert und sie ändern sich
weiter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seitdem der jetzige Staatschef 2012 das
Ruder übernommen hat greift die Führung
wieder stärker in die Wirtschaft ein das
Wachstum hat sich verlangsamt und in den
Versuch anständige Wachstumsraten
aufrecht zu erhalten hat sich die
Verschuldung von Unternehmen Haushalten
und der öffentlichen Hand vervielfacht
auf diese Weise haben sich also die
Wirtschaftsdaten allmählich nach und
nach verschlechtert bis wir eben an
einem Kipppunkt angekommen sind und ja
china hat noch immer viele Stärken aber
die Wahrheit ist dass der explosive
wohlstandsschub den dieses Land
jahrelang erlebt hat jetzt nicht mehr da
ist shisha Ping kümmert sich weitaus
mehr um die soziale politische und
wirtschaftliche Kontrollfunktion der
Kommunistischen Partei als um das
Wohlstandsniveau der Bevölkerung
natürlich waren auch seine Vorgänger
keine Demokraten der große Unterschied
ist jedoch dass die Menschen damals
immerhin spürten dass nicht alles was
sie tun einzig und allein dem macht
Erhalt der KP Bonzen dient sondern auch
dem Volk und dies ist Unterschied eben
nicht mehr jeden Fall wir können
festhalten dass China unter ihm seine
Öffnung immer weiter revidiert es wird
sogar wieder totalitärer die Zeit und
aller Fortschritt der letzten Jahrzehnte
werden zurückgedreht mit allen
Konsequenzen die das mit sich bringt
die Frage ist nun also was die
chinesische Regierung überhaupt zu tun
gedenkt um die Krise noch zu vermeiden
nun wahrscheinlich kommt sie mit ihrem
gleichen alten Formeln daher und das
Problem ist eben dass sie dieses Mal im
Kontext der jetzigen Lage sowohl Inland
als auch in der Welt offenbar nicht mehr
ausreichen um Krisen zu vermeiden hatte
ich chinesische Regierung immer auf
fiskalische und vor allem auch monetäre
Anreize zurückgegriffen das heißt sie
hat die öffentlichen Ausgaben erhöht und
die Kreditvergabe stark ausgeweitet
plumpe quantitative Maßnahmen ohne
qualitative Verbesserungen erinnert ihr
euch noch wie ich gesagt habe dass Tina
die Zinssätze gesenkt hat nun das fällt
genau in diese Kategorie sie haben auch
große Kreditlinien für Unternehmen
genehmigt und senken die Anforderungen
für den Immobilienkauf denn in der
Vergangenheit hat das ja immer
funktioniert allerdings zu den Preis
dass die offenen Schulden um ein
Vielfaches gestiegen sind und jetzt
scheint die Verschuldung zu hoch zu sein
als dass diese Politik noch viel
ausrichten könnte tatsächlich ist die
Geldmenge in den letzten Monaten viel
schneller gewachsen als der Bestand an
Krediten außerdem dürfte eine
Zinssenkung wenn die amerikanische
Zentralbank zugleich genau das Gegenteil
tut den Kapitalabfluss aus dem Land
erhöhen
[Musik]
zudem hat Präsident alle staatlichen
Instanzen dazu aufgerufen die Ausgaben
für Infrastruktur zu erhöhen damit diese
eine Art wirtschaftlichen Puffer gegen
den Abschwung in Immobiliensektor bilden
14 Juli 2022 China stellt 1,1 Billionen
Dollar zur Unterstützung
vonfrastrukturschubbereit aber halt
momentchen so einfach geht es nicht
warum weil eine der wichtigsten
Geldquellen der kommunalen und
regionalen Ämter und Behörden der
Verkauf von Grundstücken und Einnahmen
aus den Immobiliensektor sind und wisst
ihr was die Grundstücksverkäufe sind in
12 Monaten und 30 Prozent zurückgegangen
das erklärt warum diese staatlichen
Institutionen seit 2022 im Rekordtempo
Schulden aufnehmen um alle Arten von
Infrastruktur zu finanzieren zum
Beispiel Industrieparks verkehrsplätze
Wasserversorgung Mobilfunknetze und
Rechenzentren das alles klingt
wahnsinnig solide und innovativ bringt
uns aber direkt zu dem Problem zurück
dass wir zuvor schon erkannt haben
versucht Chinas das Wachstum aufrecht zu
erhalten indem er Schulden macht und
Infrastruktur errichtet die aber nicht
rentabel ist weil sie größtenteils
einfach nicht gebraucht wird und da sie
eben nicht rentabel sind tragen diese
Projekte nach ihrer Fertigstellung nicht
mehr zum Wirtschaftswachstum bei aber
die Schulden bleiben und die Zinsen
werden fällig anstatt mal eine
Verschnaufpause in Kauf zu nehmen um
auch mal darüber nachzudenken ob es
nicht sinnvoll wäre seinem Volk dem
extremen materialistischen
reinökonomischen wachstumsorientierten
Gesellschaftsmodell als allgemeinem
glücksspender auch alternative Angebote
zu machen um die Lebensqualität zu
erhöhen wird weiterhin wie verrückt all
dem schlechten Geld noch mehr Geld
hinterher geworfen denn er weiß nur zu
genau diese Alternativen Angebote
Stichwort klassisch statt Masse und
individuelle Freiheit statt
kollektivistischer Totalitarismus würden
zwar eine große Chance für das
chinesische Volk darstellen aber ein
gewaltiges Risiko für seine eigene Macht
kurz gesagt China mag immer noch viele
Stärken und viele Wirtschaftssektoren
haben die dynamisch entwickeln aber die
Gesamtsituation des Landes hat sich in
den letzten Jahren drastisch
verschlechtert jetzt scheint das Land am
Rande einer wirtschaftlichen und
vielleicht auch finanziellen Krise zu
stehen einer Krise bei der es überhaupt
nicht klar ist wie die Regierung sie
überhaupt bewältigen will
denn wie wir gesehen haben funktionieren
die üblichen Mittel und Formeln dieses
Mal vielleicht nicht mehr könnte das
also bedeuten dass die Ära des
stürmischen chinesischen Wachstums zu
Ende gegangen ist nun ja immer mehr
Analysten deuten jedenfalls diese
Möglichkeit an und auch skischempfängen
scheint es gut zu wissen versucht er
doch die sich verschlechternde
Wirtschaftslage mit einem deutlich
aggressiveren Nationalismus zu
kompensieren eine Strategie die noch für
alle schlecht ausgehen könnte aber auch
das ist ein Thema für ein weiteres Video
das wir bereits in der Mache haben und
bis dahin seid erstmal ihr an der Reihe
glaubt ihr dass China letztlich in eine
schwere Wirtschaftskrise rutscht oder
denkt ihr im Gegenteil das ist den Land
gelingen wird alle seine Probleme zu
überwinden haltet ihr es für möglich
dass das sogenannte chinesische Modell
scheitern könnte welches alternative
Gesellschaftsmodell könnte eurer Meinung
nach China wieder aus der Patsche helfen
und was traut ihr shamping zu was alles
wird er tun um an der Macht zu bleiben
wie immer sind wir auf eure angeregte
Diskussion schon außerordentlich Gespann
ich hoffe dass euch dieses Video
gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht auch
etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja gib
uns bitte ein Like fallen Freunden und
vergessliches Abo mit Glöckchen um
keines unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
den PayPal Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video mach's gut
und bis bald
[Musik]